- [Voiceover] So I see on your resume
you just graduated college.
- I did, I did just
graduate college, cum laude.
- [Voiceover] So, what are
some things you learned
in college that you think
would apply to this job?
(percussive music)
- Um, I think I learned a lot in college
that would help me in this job,
a lot of skills I picked up on.
I learned things like
teamwork, multitasking,
I think I learned leadership skills.
All right, so you're
gonna be the D.D. tonight,
yeah you are, nose goes, bam.
I'm really good with managing money.
I am a good problem solver.
Hey, Dad?
I always had a good academic record.
So if I need a 70% to pass the class,
and I got a 78 on the
paper, then that means
I only need a 71 on the final.
Hey guys, I'm going out tonight!
I'm a good communicator.
I have an astounding perseverance.
I am quite the motivator.
Chug, chug, chug!
I love researching things,
I have good time management skills,
I have passion.
Woo! We going to the natty championship!
And yeah, I really think that
college prepared me for this job.
- [Voiceover] Well, everything looks good,
except for the fact that this
is an entry level position
and we do require three
years of experience.
So...
this won't work out.
- Yeah, makes sense.
Silly me.
(percussive music)